[Music]
and where is the love news where is the
I like that song yeah that's all I can
hear is old water gotta be it's old
microphone just just in a timber timber
link what ha ha ha nothing like
instruments put out as falling apart
yeah don't eat that 100 I submitted by
the Key Club oh gee Club I was vice
president of Key Club what is key no
body can it helped out for colleges for
this G Club is a community service thing
where were you gonna help out the
community I'm gonna show up once to
anything yeah how are you the president
if I walked up I was like vote for me
and they did that's the dumbest [ __ ]
thing that club ever did focus ok think
that it is bogus no [ __ ] oh yeah libido
but Key Club conventions were the
[ __ ] [ __ ] because of the girl yup so
you got like chicks from every part of
the [ __ ] state would come and they
would let us throw parties a shooting we
have my hotel particle to lure girls
didn't make me horny
little prick you poke I had different
taste back then I like girls that
[ __ ] bleach their hair had eyebrows
that looked like the McDonald's arches
purple you know what I'm talking about
my future
hi a woman who spent $150,000 on
matchmaking services is now suing over
bad days yeah maybe you're a [ __ ] you
ever think about that [ __ ] yeah cuz
like straight up and see that's I don't
want that because usually those like
that one person this is like oh all
these people that I meet are [ __ ]
but the one stable factor is your
guardian exactly so you might be the
[ __ ]
true how about when you think everybody
is great you just don't know why they
keep leaving you oh I mean but then it's
so you that yeah because they can't see
their flaws
cuz I find it very odd if you got
matched up like 30 or 40 times like not
one person like you that muley means
that you're [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah or your
standards are just unrealistic like what
have you everybody like you but you
don't like them yeah yeah yeah your
standard dirty manager [ __ ] up then
who the [ __ ] do you think you are Judge
Joe yeah so this woman her name is
Darlene she's 62 years old
I like that oh yeah she's a divorced
mother of four she's 62 but she's China
stove oh damn I thought it was like a
young 22 year old like brunette girl but
that make sense
and I just pictured her hair color yeah
everything dude she was like kind of hot
but not really way to tan you know I'm
saying I pictured somebody that worked
too hard and never got married because
they were so focused on this like patio
furniture company and she was a big boss
any to management just kind of seems
like the industry that she would get
into you know and she worked so hard to
the point where she was like I don't
need no [ __ ] Maya and inches
all right [ __ ] I kind of lonely you know
speaking of patio furniture there's guy
that I meant at the fan of ours and he
watches us religiously in the Vietnam
yeah he's Australian dude hey what's up
oh yeah what's up dude I completely
forgot your name and I also lost your
card but watching this leave a comment
bro but he loves me not gonna read but
what does this have to do with patio
furniture
he owns a patio furniture company in
Vietnam I see so if we ever want to go
to Vietnam he says that he'll take care
of oh I'm gonna do it the [ __ ] techno
if you guys ever want a couch in Vietnam
see all the patio furniture company is
how I got that connection yeah that's
yeah but isn't that crazy though
anything's good it means lutely
that it is not crazy he took it lived in
Vietnam
ozzie an RV yeah because that he moved
12 to 20 years I know but he's aa see
that's good to me I've never seen a
white guy
your parents are Korean that [ __ ]
move to the US I speak English I know
this city English yeah I don't know what
you're talking about you moved there
when he was an adult so did your parents
have you met an audience what are the
three enemies have you have you seen one
I'm in your [ __ ] face that's kid tiny
balls all right he has a point as a
point I get a point of view because
every country is already pre primed to
speak English BAM like your family they
already teach English in Mexico English
in Korea yeah they don't teach
Vietnamese in Australia land and so when
they go over there they're happy they're
not buying it well I get it but he said
this person that they're from twelve to
twenty years I was living as rain my
mother my mother had lived in this
country for thirty years still can't
speak English we've just met a white
chick that lived in China for two years
and she's like [ __ ] fluent in Chinese
but I've seen that before I never seen
the building leaving nummies that's a
very difficult language no connectome
muck technic so that you're [ __ ]
drowning all the time come on why did
you do water so hard that my language
[Laughter]
we are the duck anyways another story so
this woman Darlene she wanted to find
someone to spend like the rest every
year you know her after she's retired
and so she and they're painting up this
company who is a pretty well-known
matchmaking service so it's ran by jill
keller and this company called Keller
International and it's a
california-based company they jill has
even appeared on NBC's this woman blonde
chick I fainted on the airplane on the
airplane magazine this is always
matchmaker lady yup that her there's
always a big I know I couldn't find my
age I was about to say do she look
[ __ ] baby dude
Darlene she looks good for 60 like 2 or
65 years old [ __ ] yeah but I always see
that other person's ad on every single
airline I'm going on damn look at her
skin do you like Celine Dion McDonald
Trump's wife oh yeah Melania Trump yeah
so she came out on this ready for love
show and so she's really she's a
well-known as you guys know a well-known
matchmaker and so Darlene hit her up the
patio furniture name but no but I think
people that hit her up are rich and
famous yeah so apparently is in
speculated that Jennifer Aniston Paula
Abdul and David Spade and among other
celebrities have used her services they
still need [ __ ] help they probably
suck at life skills yeah I feel like
it's harder yeah can you go out and
start dating people right now to women I
find so many fans I make dreams come
true baby to women that have aged really
well that are celebrities Jennifer
Aniston and also careful of it yeah try
to get hotter the older what the [ __ ]
where's her [ __ ] wrinkles where's her
saggy titties
Gabrielle onions in Beijing they drink
placenta yo I saw this pic so I looked
up pics purposely of trying to find ugly
ass pics of Jennifer Lopez because I
wanted to feel better about myself so I
would do that for my self-esteem and I
looked up my Tara for Lopez without
makeup right she's goes good yeah her
she's gonna [ __ ] do it
she's using Africa I wish crash she says
is that the water and sleep yeah she
stays away from alcohol I so do I drink
water and we don't do yeah I really
should drink water and free but not
drinking look like JLo yeah I'm actually
13 uh I don't know
whose question are you a dreary I think
yeah I forgot to tell you guys that I
was picturing a juice ball yeah I was
picturing her basically they know these
guys and she's kind of like not you not
you you're not the type I walk but I was
thinking what if they just had shitty
quality men and I was like oh no so let
me tell you this home conversation with
himself so Darlene it so Darlene opted
for the company's most expensive option
because they range from 25,000 to 160
101 yeah Fred stolle so at the CEO level
of 150 thousand dollars at Darlene paid
she's guaranteed that her matches are
from around the world and with the
personal attention of Jill oh but she
says like the reason why she's doing
hers because she ended up with a series
of disastrous beef with men that were
just way unsuitable for her so she was
promised a hand-picked wealthy bachelors
like a group of them but instead she got
men that were married mentally unstable
physically ill pathological liars serial
lothario stalkers convicted felons and
men that were unable or unwilling to
travel for whatever reason so she just
got Paul the [ __ ] did that happen what
yeah interface is Jill going through I
mean if she's paying a hundred thousand
are you guys paying a hundred thousand
to meet and it have to be like the same
level I think she went to the Mafia
database you know like you gave her the
worst pic and so I felt badly I'm sorry
you're not a [ __ ]
oh I call her a [ __ ] but it's good ten
minutes whoo Darlene yeah you mean she
got scoot over there folks hang on let
me tell you the first no [ __ ] [ __ ]
cheering Darlene can be a [ __ ] of any
party yeah so what
and hours of filing this lawsuit both
parties agreed to settle also states are
admitting they're like up job sorry
sorry about the guy with the scar on his
face I thought we got rid of them so I
bought the jeans like Jared Fogle I
knowing all these people sure yeah and
like payment and this article they even
talked about some of her matches and
like some of the horrible experiences
that she went through like you mentioned
James Bond well one of them claims to be
part of Interpol that's tight and that
apparently he had to go away on a trip
and they had to go dark like meaning he
can't a community war anymore and then
we know someone like that yeah
and then a year later an entire year
later like he was like stringing her
along for a whole year or wasting her
time then she finds out that what
happened was that he ended up going back
to his ex so that whole time he just
wasted so that was just like one story
right so then they go into all the bad
dates that she had she saw Darlene must
be a baller perfecting the old services
is for like highly successful people or
something yeah she's a former president
of QVC's US Commerce I don't know what
that is QVC the [ __ ] over social yeah
I pick just a show and they'll just show
you different products like you can buy
this right now the hall right in I think
there's a movie about this girl really
yeah boy yes movie then cuz QVC is
[ __ ] boring deployment isn't before
Amazon yeah it was this is my jewelry
dissipation it's anything and everything
I [ __ ] hated that channel again I
know there's a movie about her really
yeah someone plays it the blonde lady
that's I forgot her name but there's a
little bit better
she [ __ ] sell mops and then she kind
of joy as it differently we got really
close enough yeah yeah Jennifer Lawrence
the blonde lady [ __ ] hey guys would you
think of that video I know you loved it
so make sure to hit that like button to
watch more videos check it out of here
[Music]